a show of british military firepower
right on russia's doorstep
they are training but where nato's
eastern border meets russia it all feels
much more serious
where are you from i'm from sandust in
the uk how's it going it's good really
good it's good to train with the
estonians and see how other nations work
and then working in different
environments
they're not here to anticipate an attack
but it is a defense mission aimed at
deterring aggression
to know the situation what it is and
we're
definitely
taken and it's uh it's a threat but we
do our job like we always do and it's to
defend our country the best way we can
nato have been in the baltics since the
annexation of crimea and the uk are now
looking at significantly stepping up the
number of british troops here
so they're training here for the
harshest of winter conditions british
estonian and french troops there are
almost a thousand british troops in
estonia right now 350 have just gone to
poland as well but the estonians say
that they are outnumbered by ten to one
by russian troops in the region
and this is why this matters here from
estonia's most eastern edge you can see
russia divided ironically by what's
known as friendship bridge like the
other baltic states it is flanked too by
russian ally belarus where an
unprecedented number of russian troops
have been moved
how significant is the russian military
presence in belarus how concerning is
that for the baltics and would you like
to see more of a presence here from nato
well we can confirm that there are
fifteen thousand already there
uh troops uh there is speculations uh
anticipation that there will be
thirty thousand if this would remain
like this
in belarus then there needs to be a
dramatic change of force exposure by
nato as well
nato troops and resources already moving
amid criticism germany haven't done
enough they've donated this field
hospital to ukraine and are sending
hundreds of troops to lithuania
but all the while diplomacy continues
russia say its security threat is the
expansion of nato the government sources
here believe the baltics are unprepared
if russia moves putin's goal to divide
nato hasn't changed they say the
opportunity though might have ali
fortescue sky news in estonia